people we just watched the first episode of
moon night uh full disclosure that we were sent
screeners for first four episodes we might watch
the second one we might watch it that's a big
maybe episode three and four we're gonna wait till
it's actually air because um apparently they're
like not finished or something and seriously why
would we wait that we can't record a reaction
it doesn't make sense but in the meantime rejects
re-re-enter reacting but what i want to do really
quick is hop in here and just quickly give our
thoughts on what we thought of the first episode
because it's brilliant it's brilliant
i am not sugar coating that whatsoever
what a setup it really is like fight club
meets indiana jones oscar isaac is amazing
wow he is so good i love steven grant already
johnny quick thoughts buddy oh dude i couldn't
agree morgan some great great camerawork great
effects great mood and tone and also great
antagonist i'll say portrayal right now by
ethan hawk as well i i'm eating it up and
i cannot wait to see more it's right up my alley
coy it feels like greg smallwood art come to life
i'm really really enjoying the entire feel of it
and i think that loki might have some competition
from my favorite show it's obviously way too
early to tell but having seen one-sixth of this
if it stays and sticks the landing if this
stays as good as it is and the sixth episode
has me feel resolved this probably will take
out loki i love that it's so immersive and
i also love that it doesn't feel like you need
to have experienced other marvel content before
i think at some point there is a threshold of too
much tying together causing negatives instead of
just inherently like oh that's funny easter
egg sometimes you need less of that to build
out your universe this is probably the biggest
world building expansion since one division it's
really special yeah it's like psychological
pure supernatural i i really loved it a lot
man i don't want to give too much away just just
know that it's uh for a first episode i'm i'm
insanely hooked into uh everything you gotta
uncover here it's gonna be it's gonna be great
stuff keep a lookout for a really in-depth
review after the reaction as well obviously
you can't post that reaction until the episode's
out well it wouldn't make sense reacting yeah
so keep a lookout for that we'll have it ready for
you by the time it comes out thank you guys for
being here subscribe and click that notification
bell swallow this one on tick tock yay